now I'd like to introduce today's
featured presenter William play wilt way
is a assistant professor in the
Department of material science and
engineering and a center fellow the
Precourt Institute for energy at
Stanford University fessor Troy has
received numerous honors including the
Mrs outstanding Young Investigator award
in 2018 the Volkswagen BASF science
award electrochemistry in 2016
Camille Dreyfus teacher scholar award in
2016 and many others in 2012 he was also
named as one of the top 35 innovators
under the age of 35 by mi t--'s
Technology Review he received his BS in
Applied Physics MS and PhD and material
science from Caltech prior to joining
Stanford in 2012 now I'd like to turn
the floor over to well thank you Joe for
the introduction and it is my great
pleasure to give you a brief
presentation on the future of energy
storage so if you look at the costs of
lithium-ion battery for example since
2010 has declined by almost 80 percent
and the trend is only increasing on the
other hand if you look at the cost of
generating electricity renewably that
cost has even gone agonda even more for
example for wind electricity since the
80s has gone down by 90% and for solar
that has gone down by 99 percent in the
past two decades and if you combine the
decline costs of storage and generation
of renewable electricity that leads to
two very interesting question the first
question is in the sector of
transportation so what are the remaining
research development needed to fully
electrify and convert our internal
combustion engine fleet to electric
vehicle and a greater question and a
bigger challenge is for the grid so can
we combine this low-cost renewable
electricity and low cost storage and
compete on cost with conventional
electricity generated from
you will purely up cos so these are the
two question I'm going to try to give
additional details I will discuss them
both from a business perspective and
also a technology perspective and let me
just state the take-home message which
is you have to look at the problem both
from the business side and the
technology side so I'll go over some
details in the next 45 minutes so let me
start with a plot showing you the
tremendous growth in v's this is
plotting the millions of vehicles for
the past eight years from 2011 and
projection into 2019 and you can see we
sold our first million electric vehicle
in 2015 then the second million 2016 and
now we have sold over 4 million
passenger EVs and within the next year
we'll add another million to that the
numbers are big but they are very small
compared to the global industry of 1
billion vehicle so that tells you some
of the opportunities going forward in
terms of fully electrifying and I don't
think I have to highlight the importance
of battery technology for transportation
so I think most people can appreciate
the growth abhi B's perhaps a harder
problem to see is how energy storage is
impacting the electrical grid and here
I'm showing you the global installed
capacity for renewable generation so
this is showing in green for wind and in
yellow for solar and you can see over
the past 18 years the increase in this
capacity of wind and solar has just been
enormous now we're approaching
approximately 1 terawatt of installed
capacity for wind and solar so the
electricity grid is changing very
quickly and one of the key challenges
how does the grid cope with the
generation of what we call variable
electricity so these are not resources
which is available all the time the Sun
doesn't shine all the time and the wind
doesn't blow all the time so how do we
think about change in the grid to
accommodate for this variable generation
of electricity is one of the key
just going forward so let me talk about
energy storage
in the context of the electricity grid
these are plots showing the utility
scale energy storage installation that
is forecasting from 2017 all the way to
and here on the Left we're looking at
the energy storage in terms of utility
and on the right it's the installed
capacity for distributed energy storage
so utility means very concentrated so
these are power plants tile energy
storage technology and on the right
these are distributed or a home based or
business based energy storage and I
won't get in the details of this plot
which is being distributed over many
countries but the key aspect is the
trend energy storage is going to grow
very rapidly both at the utility level
and at the distributed level and the
reason is actually quite straightforward
one easy way to deal with variable
generation of electricity is to be able
to buffer it with energy storage
technology such as batteries so one of
the key driver for energy storage is
policy and being here at Stanford let me
start with California so there are
several very notable policies that is
driving the investment in this area for
example the mandate to have 1.8 gigawatt
of installed storage by 2024 and more
recently to go completely carbon-free
electricity by 2045 that would just
announced two months ago you can see
similar initiatives in the policy area
in Arizona New York Massachusetts Texas
and many places in the US and globally
as well in the US the state-level policy
it is currently what's driving energy
storage on the grid level and this is
going to be a very significant factor
going forward in the growth of the
industry so let me give some specifics
on battery technology battery it is not
the only technology that can be used for
grid storage I will talk about a variety
of them
later in the webinar but just show you
one example this is for battery based
technology and you're basically seeing
almost zero installation in capacity
prior to 2010 but because the cost of
lithium-ion matter has gone down so much
you can see that the declining cost is
almost matched with the installed
capacity which is really taking off
since 2010 as well this is a great start
but we're still very far from matching
this to the one terawatt generation
capacity I showed earlier from solar and
wind so this highlights the challenge we
have to deal with and I will talk about
a little bit some of the technological
and the business drivers behind getting
the storage capacity to match up with
that of generation so let me talk a
little bit about the application of
energy storage in the context of the
grid so we can all appreciate how energy
storage can help with transportation in
terms of electric vehicle the grid is a
much more complex system and you can
think about the utility of storage into
context of the duration of storage so
how long do you have to store
electricity for in order to tackle some
of these various applications and what
we send applications each application
has a revenue associated with it so this
is driving some of the technical
economic behind storage on for example
whether utility companies will
incorporate storage or not or do they go
with traditional means of providing
electricity for example through natural
gas power plants so let's start at the
bottom on the level of seconds you have
things like startup of the grid so you
have to provide some initial energy if
the grid was down and you have to
restart it the second one is frequency
regulations if you look at your
electricity output it is very stable
okay but that only happens when demand
and supply of electricity are perfectly
matched and sometime it is difficult to
match it so you have to have some amount
of buffering so that your electricity
will come out at the right voltage in
the right frequency so 120 volt and 60
Hertz in the United States then you go
on to minutes so these are what's called
so to accommodate for variations in the
grid you have to have electricity that
you can provide on a reserved basis
under ordered minutes then keep moving
up you have what's called peak shaving
and this is corresponding to the fact
that there are demands of electricity
that is high and low in the day and when
the demand gets too high this puts a lot
of stress on the system on the grid so
being able to shave that peak to
decrease the peak requirement of
electricity from conventional sources
it's important and then if we move up
even more in the purple box we talk
about curtailment so this is where there
is so much renewable being generated for
example from solar wind you can't use it
all and if you can't use it all you have
to start either dumping the electricity
away or you have to think about
basically curtailing it and this is a
significant revenue loss for the
electrical electricity grid companies as
well and on the very very top right you
have seasonal or long-duration resource
shifting I'll talk a lot a little bit
about this as well so you have different
outputs of electricity from solar
throughout the year so we are have high
solar output in the summer and lower
solar output in the winter but the
demand is actually somewhat uniform so
being able to shift the ability to shift
the electricity between seasons could
also be very important and another
important source of revenue and if you
look at this plot from left to right it
ohso shows you how important it is
dependent on the penetration of
renewable so when the Renewable
penetration if you want it to be a
hundred percent you have to talk about
seasonal storage but if you only wanted
to be ten percent then maybe we can get
away with just peak shaving so let me
show you one example of a typical
one-week electricity generation here so
here we have green it's the generation
of wind and we have here in yellow at
the top line that is the total
electricity load so if you look at the
green here from left to right you can
see it's highly variable it can be
almost zero at times and it can be very
large at other times and if you look at
the low profile the up-and-down week
reflects a cyclic demand of the day
higher during the daytime and lower
during nighttime and where you have a
peak demand and low wind output is where
you have to provide electricity from
something other than wind and this is
where we turn up our natural gas power
plan and on the other hand if you have a
high supply below demand this is where
we have to curtail which means that the
grid electricity grid companies are
paying wind farms to basically turn off
that wind turbines because they cannot
take the electricity and that sometimes
can result in negative pricing so the
grid companies are paying for
electricity not to be generated and if
you look in the middle of the plot I'm
highlighting two potential areas you can
for example shift the resources so right
around say here February 24th at a noon
you have high wind generation and then
at midnight you have low wind generation
so if you can move the electricity
around by that 12 hour I started that 20
36 hour period that can also provide
additional revenue to the great
companies one other application is
frequency regulation this slide is
showing quite a bit but let me just tell
you that regulation in frequency happens
on a very fast time scale so this is
typically on the order of seconds and so
these various plot basically shows how
effective it is to match the frequency
of the electricity to the between the
demand and the supply on the top right
you have a case where you have battery
based buffering so the two curves are
matched perfectly so there's no lag
behind between the supply and demand but
if you go to say something like a hydro
storage so this is using water by
pumping up the hill and down you have a
slightly greater mismatch because of the
lack time in providing the electricity
and then if you look at a turbine base
combined cycle on the very lower plot
there you can see that the lack is even
greater
so the
tells you that the ability to maintain a
very stable grid has to do with how fast
you're able to buffer the electricity
and battery provides a really good way
to do so and this can directly generate
revenue for the electricity grid so
here's one example many of you might
have heard about the installation of a
100 megawatt 129 megawatt hour battery
system in Australia that was installed
by Tesla in 2017 the main application of
this battery system which is based on
looking around batteries is to provide
for frequency generation which means
it's used to buffer the electricity so
that the frequency is held constant so
100 megawatt or 121 megawatt hour is not
a very big number but it is very
exciting to see even a small
installation like this can have a
substantial impact on the type of
storage used for frequency regulation so
if you look at the right the plot of the
first bar shows you q4 in 2017 right
before the installation of this battery
system you can see battery was a very
small percentage of what's used for
frequency regulation of the grid and is
mainly powered by coal and hydro okay so
you're using coal and water to provide
the buffering needed to regulate the
frequency of electricity in Australia
but just the next quarter so three
months later you can see battery grew
from about one percent to over ten
percent as the mean to regulate the
frequency of electricity so a small
installation like this one can have a
huge impact and this is for Australia as
a country so this is very exciting to
see how a small battery system can have
such a large impact for frequency
regulation another application that I
alluded to earlier is peak shaving so
let me get in some detail here so peak
shaving basically reflects the mismatch
between the consumption of electricity
and the
generation of electricity and here
because the generation of renewable
electricity is variable you have to
buffer the differences between the two
so one application of peak shifting s as
follows you have the top of the demand
at about 6:00 p.m. this is when everyone
goes home turn on electricity maybe turn
on the AC if you're in the summer in the
southern states in the US and at
nighttime for example the electricity
demand is much lower so one idea is that
you can generate excess electricity when
you have lower demand and shifted by
about 12 hours to higher demand one
particular application could be in
storing wind electricity so when often
blows at night so if you're able to
store that basically you can charge your
battery at night and then you discharge
the battery during the day when the
demand is higher this will lessen the
demand on the electricity in the peak
hours so the ability to shave this peak
can stabilize the grid and make it more
economical for the grid to be operated
so one example of this peak shaving is
the California duct curve some of you
may have heard this in the popular press
the duct curve basically shows you the
shape of the generation of non renewable
electricity and how it varies throughout
the day so if you look at the plot on
the left it is showing you the
generation of electricity from
non-renewable sources okay so these are
primarily your natural gas power plants
in California for a typical spring day
and the curve on the top in grey is the
actual in 2012 and as you go down it
shows you the prediction to 2020 and the
prediction was made in 2013 so you can
see that because the solar insolation
was still quite low back in 2012 so your
generation of non renewable electricity
is fairly flat during the day but as
time went on the solar installation
increased in California which means
you're outputting much more renewable
generation during the daytime
and as that renewable generation went up
that means the generation of
conventional electricity from natural
gas and others have to go down okay and
that's why from 2012 to 2015 you're
seeing the formation of the site profile
of a duck which tells you that you are
needing less electricity during the day
because you have more solar electricity
to work with what problem does this give
you well you have to shut down the
generation of non renewable electricity
during the day and you have to turn it
back up right around 4:00 to 5:00 p.m.
when the Sun is beginning to set and
that gives you the neck of the curve and
if you look at the number here we're
talking about the ramping of
approximately 10,000 megawatt over a
three hour period this is a tremendous
challenge and as a stress on the grid
and this was the prediction back in 2013
how good were the predictions not very
good in fact what we are today we're
already way past the 2020 projection in
terms of the DA curve so we're very
close to the bottom of this curve which
means we are shutting down a tremendous
amount of conventional electricity
generation during the daytime and we
have to turn it back up over a three
hour period and the plot on the right
just shows you how much ramp we're
talking about 10,000 megawatt to put
some context 10,000 megawatt is half of
the Australia grid so in California we
have to turn up electricity that is
equal to half of the grid utilization in
Australia so this dot curve it's a
tremendous consideration when it comes
to technologies that can mitigate the
darker let me show another example of
curtailment so this is a projection in
2020 for the Western grid in the United
States showing how various form of
electricity or various forms of
generation for electricity so at the
very bottom you have nuclear so that is
very steady over time so it doesn't vary
so the power plants are running uniform
Emily then you have coal and hydro so
you can see coal actually goes down
during the day and the reason is very
simple the grid company turns off coal
first because has the largest carbon
footprint and the reason you turn off
coal is because during the day time you
have the increase in solar and that is
captured in yellow there so this
essentially shows you the different
types of electricity that is being
generated day today and if you look at
the very very top there you can see
curtailment
so there you have so much electricity
that you couldn't turn off enough of the
coal and other conventional generation
so that you have to curtail the
renewables by paying the renewable
generation company not to generate to
turn off their resources and this is a
hit on the economics because the grid
operator are paying money to the
renewable generators and the renewable
generators are not able to generate the
revenue they originally wanted to
generate when they install the equipment
so this shows you how dynamic the grid
is it's really incredible to see the ups
and downs of various generation of
electricity throughout just one day and
as another example of resource shifting
these plots are showing you the resource
and demand profile on the left for
California and on the right for the
United States for the entire year ok so
you can see the demand it's fairly flat
ok in California is fairly flat in the
u.s. is a little bit less flat and that
is the or the orange curve there but
what is very interesting is if you look
at the renewable electricity so that's
in blue on the left and on the plot on
the right is separated into both wind
and solar in purple and yellow
respectively and there you can see a
significant mismatch you can see that we
have more generation during the summer
month and less generation over the
winter month so the opportunity
here is can we align our resources with
our demand by shifting electricity
around seasons so can we take some of
those electricity generated in the month
of May to August and we can shift that
to the consumption in the winter okay so
this is something that is not yet
possible but seasonal shifting of
electricity is a huge opportunity and as
that commented not earlier if we want
renewable to penetrate the grid
completely we have to tackle this
challenge these are a few more plots of
simulations so what this is plotting
it's basically how much capacity over
building we need one means no over
building and two three four means we
have to over build the solar and wind by
a certain amount and the x-axis is
showing you the amount of renewable
penetration so zero means no renewables
and hundred means completely renewable
the black curve shows you the amount of
over building if you have only have no
storage and as you go to the lighter
green curve it shows you what happens if
you have storage one day for day and one
month so as you increase storage then
you get to decreased amount of over
building of solar and wind and the
reason is simple if you don't have
storage and you want a certain amount of
renewable penetration that means you
have to have more than you need so then
you can generate enough solar and wind
when the Sun is not shining or when the
wind is not blowing but if you have
storage then you're able to shift the
resources around so that even when the
Sun is not shining and the wind is not
blowing you can still use the renewable
and that decreases the amount of over
building that is required and it's very
interesting to see the various cases the
top curve shows you what happens if you
purely have solar ok because solar is
intermittent on the daily basis this
highlights the importance of storage so
if you want 50% penetration of solar in
the United States that means you need to
have storage without it you can only get
to approximately 50% penetration when it
becomes impossible to supply and this is
simply reflecting the fact that the Sun
doesn't shine at night but if you look
at the bottom cases if you go to 50/50
mixture of solar and wind the curve
shifts to the right which means for a
given amount of penetration you need
much less over building and this
reflects the fact that wind is
intermittent on a different time scale
it's intermittent on a day several day
basis so if you mix just the right
amount of wind and solar you're able to
have less over building for a given
amount of penetration and if you go to a
hundred percent win on the bottom that
also showcases as well but regardless of
what scenario you consider you need PAP
storage in order to reach high degree of
penetration of renewable electricity in
the grid system so now let me talk about
the alternatives so we talked a lot
about the various application and the
business need for storage whether it is
seasonal storage with there is daily
storage or peak shaving energy storage
is not the only way to do it there are a
lot of competitions that is already
available today and probably one of the
most attractive alternative is natural
gas pker plans so a peak or basically
reflects the fact that these natural gas
power plants are not turned on all the
time it is turned on when the demand of
electricity increases for example around
3 p.m. when the generation of renewable
goes down and this is basically showing
you the cost of electricity per megawatt
hour shifters so this is talking about
if I have to move one megawatt hour of
electricity around for a certain amount
of time what will be the cost and you
can see actually technology like lithium
battery is high on this plot okay and
using a natural gas peaker plan is
actually very cost effective this is
based on today's cost of lithium-ion
battery technology but look at the same
plot on the right in 2030 the projection
is that lithium ion battery will
actually become less expensive than
natural power natural gas power plants
so this is showing you the importance of
continuing to push the cost of battery
technology so that it can compete with
other ways of shifting electricity for
example through peaker plants on cost
okay and I want to emphasize this one
more time is that for something as
enormous as the grid Technic anomic is
the principle driving force you have to
think primarily about cost so now let's
get into the technology aspect so if we
want to shift energy around whether it
is on the order of an hour three hours a
day or across the season there are many
different metrics that must be satisfied
at the same time and this plot here
shows you just a few of those metrics
and I'll walk you through from the top
starting with calendar life so calendar
life basically tells you for a
particular energy storage technology how
long can you use it for it doesn't
matter how many times you use it it's
just a calendar so is it ten years
twenty years and this determines the
cost of electricity that is amortized
over the lifetime of the technology
going around in the clockwise fashion
the next one is cycle life so this is
how many times you can cycle the battery
so if you're storing electricity on a
daily basis then you will need to cycle
at about 300 times in a year if you're
doing frequency regulation like the
Australia example I showed earlier then
you're doing multiple cycles or tens of
cycles a day the next one is energy cost
so this is basically looking at how much
does it take to store a certain amount
of energy so this would be the dollar
per kilowatt hour that have shown
earlier the next one is energy density
so this is how heavy the technology
would be giving an amount of energy
stored the next one is power cost so
this is looking at the cost of
delivering electricity at a certain rate
so for those of you not familiar with
energy and power
in the context of an electric vehicle
energy tells you how far you can drive
the car so that's the range and the
power basically tells you how fast you
can either charge the car or how fast
you can accelerate the car so their
costs associated with both keep going
clockwise fashion ramp rate so this is
reflecting how fast you're able to
charge and discharge the particular
energy storage technology so we talked
quite a bit about the duct curve so that
particular application will require you
to be able to charge and discharge
energy storage technology over hours but
if you're talking about frequency
regulation that period can be quite a
bit shorter as well round trip
efficiency this is basically telling you
how much of the electricity you put into
the technology you can actually get out
so we're a hundred percent round-trip
efficient system that means every bit of
energy you put in you can take out and
this also determines the cost of storage
as well safety is very important you
want to have an energy storage
technology that is safe over the
lifetime of the system and this applies
for both large scale utility
installations and also home or
transportation temperature range is
important we have many participants here
from different parts of the world
sometime he gets very hot in the summer
sometime it gets very cold in the winter
to have a technology that perform over
the broad range of temperature and those
of you who have electric vehicle can
appreciate the fact that in the winter
months then your performance is decrease
for example for looking around battery
and that highlights one of the weakness
of that particular technology and the
final one is the volumetric energy
density so this is how much you can
store per size okay so that in
combination with the gravimetric energy
density basically
tells you how big and how heavy the
particular technology has to be the
challenge with energy storage technology
is that you have to satisfy many of
these at the same time and the plot in
the middle basically shows you two
example technologies in which you don't
have complete meeting of all the metrics
okay so there's no silver bullet and
depending on the application you can
weigh these metrics differently
so for example for transportation graph
the metric and volumetric energy
densities are very important but for
grid application to Canada life is very
important so as I will talk about in the
next 10 minutes or so is really thinking
about what use case you would like a
particular technology to serve and
depending on the use cases the
technology will be different and there
is no silver bullet so this is why we
need a wide range of energy storage
technology to meet the different type of
applications that we have so this is my
personal view and cost of vacation of
energy storage technologies I divided
them by the physical storage mechanism
so going from the left we have
electromagnetic these will be
technologies such as super capacitors we
have thermal storage so this is storing
energy in the form of heat this is most
notable in the form of molten salt that
is used for concentrated solar power
whereby you concentrate solar light and
you generate heat and that he can be
sort by heating something up like a
molten salt the next one is probably the
most the one that has received the most
amount of attention is electric chemical
and bet the poster child of
electrochemical storage is lithium-ion
batteries but you also have a wide range
of other battery technology LED acid
flow battery and so forth further on the
right we have mechanical and the poster
child for mechanical is palm hydro
storage so you take electricity you take
water and you pump it up the hill that's
how you charge up a palm hydro system
and then water it goes down the hill
this is how
get electricity out you can do this not
only with water that you can use air as
a medium and you can also use other
things as well
masses rocks even by moving up and down
the hill and the final one is chemical
so we have the opportunity to take
electricity and generate chemicals such
as hydrogen and then we can combust it
subsequently and then to make
electricity again so these are the
various aspects I don't have that much
time today so I'll only briefly
highlight a few examples but I would
like the audience to appreciate the wide
range of technologies that be
investigated today at universities
National Labs and Industry to try to get
this work at the scale I alluded to
earlier in my talk so let me look at the
installation capacity by energy storage
by far the technology of preference
today is pump hydro ok an overwhelming
amount of energy today are being stored
by pumping water up and down if you look
at other forms of storage thermal
electric chemical or other it's very
small it barely shows up on the plot on
the left and the plot on the right
basically shows a blow-up of those three
things ok it's just technology other
than pom hydro so there you have a
significant participation of thermal
storage so storing energy in the form of
heat lithium-ion battery is the biggest
one now in the electrochemical area and
you also have other installation in
mechanical for example storing it in
compressed air or by turning a wheel
around and spinning it the opportunity
for the future is how can we develop
different technology to reach the same
level of economy as pom hydro and
ultimately to exceed it and the reason
why pom hydro has limitation is because
is geography dependent and water
resources always a consideration as well
but let me get right into lithium ion
battery this is something that has
really captured the attention
of the public in the past decade because
of the rapid explosion of electric
vehicles a battery technology is
actually fairly straightforward
you are shuttling atoms such as lithium
between a low energy reservoir and a
high energy reservoir so in a manner of
speaking this is not very different than
palm hydro except the energy carrier is
not water and pumping up a difference in
height but is really a lithium that is
being pumped around a difference in
chemistry between the two side of the
battery which we call the negative
electrode sometimes it's called the
anode and the positive electrode
sometime called the cathode so the
ability to move this energy carrier
lithium around the two electrode is how
a battery works one of the most
attractive thing about a battery is how
inexpensive it has become so if you look
at the table on the top right it shows
you the various parameters for the
technology currently we are looking at
greater than 2 gigawatt if it's dock
capacity typical duration now based on
the economy is about 2 1 to 4 hours for
grid and as already serving the need of
electric vehicle the lifetime is about
several thousand recharge cycles and the
can normal life could be on the order of
about 10 years round trip efficiency is
very high about 90 percent of the
electricity you put in you can take it
out the cost is extremely attractive
today for transportation but it is quite
far from what is needed for the
electrical grid I didn't get into the
economics of the grid but if you want to
have a significant penetration of
electricity storage using battery you
need to look at significantly under $100
per kilowatt hour for diurnal storage
meaning across date and if you want to
look at say storage across several days
or a week you need to reach about $20 to
kilowatt hours so we're still about 20x
off to reach in that goal so new
technology is certainly needed and
probably what is most impressive in
looking amount on battery is the scaling
exercise
that we have went through so the plot on
the left shows you the dollar per
kilowatt hour on a battery pack level
has gone from over a thousand per
kilowatt hour just in 2013 to now
slightly anticipated to below $100 by
2025 and approaching $50 per kilowatt
hour so this is extremely attractive as
the cost goes down new applications will
come up so as the cost down then you can
store electricity for longer periods of
time for example for the electrical grid
and the cost of transportation for EVs
will also go down as well and the cost
decline will be matched with growth in
the installed capacity and that is
what's shown on the right and is truly
exciting to think that the lithium-ion
battery market should in the next ten
years reach over one trillion dollars
worldwide these is a plot showing you
the companies which are involved in
manufacturing lithium-ion battery a
majority of these companies are in China
some of them are in Korea and elsewhere
in the world as well and most company
have been announcing new capacities of
this plot as already outdated and we're
seeing numbers even large today in order
for the industry to meet the demands for
transportation and increasingly for grid
storage application for lithium-ion
batteries so what is the ultimate limit
of the cost of lithium-ion battery so I
showed a projection down to 70 and $50
two kilowatt hour so fundamentally what
sets the floor of the cost of battery
technology is the material cost so this
bar shows you the projection of costs
from 2015 to 2025 so you can see the
cost of manufacturing the cost of
assembling the batteries into a pack
will continue to go down but the cost of
the material will not decrease
dramatically so the material costs will
set the cost floor so basically if you
look at the projection going forward to
the material costs will dominate the
cost of the battery pack so this is
showing you the trend in the elemental
cost this is the sum of the three
expensive component and batteries of
cobalt nickel and lithium and you can
see because of the rise in demand you
have now a sudden rise in cobalt price
over the past few years and this is
going to be a significant constraint so
one opportunity is can we design new
battery chemistry that do not use these
expensive elements and this will be one
pathway toward lowering the cost for
which is set by the material cost
another thing to think about for
batteries is cost that is levelized by
the lifetime so the cost
I've been showing so far is level wise
only by the energy so dollar per
kilowatt hour but different battery
technology have different lifetime so
for transportation we need maybe a
thousand cycles so if you think about a
a car with a 250 mile range 1000 cycle
means it's a two twenty two hundred
fifty thousand mile and that likely
exceeds the lifetime of cars in most use
cases but for grid application we need
much more we need thousands or ten
thousand life a cycle life and when you
start dividing the cost by the lifetime
the equation changes so for example this
plot shows you different technologies in
terms of the cost per kilowatt hour and
the cycle life some of these technology
are not used in transportation today
because the energy density isn't high
enough but if your primary consideration
was not the energy density say you build
a big battery system in the desert or
elsewhere then you have to actually
worry about cost more than the density
and the plot on the right that shows you
once you level wise the cost by the
cycle I of the battery then different
winners emerge so the present technology
we use today are actually fairly high in
the levelized cost because you are
achieving you're trading the lifetime of
the battery for high
energy density but for certain use case
like the grid you may want a lower
energy density but a much longer life
time and there are new chemistry's out
there that can potentially deliver that
combination of metrics so this is
something else to think about too in
terms of developing the right chemistry
and the right technology that will hit
the needs of the market one other
application that is emerging as Second
Life batteries from electric vehicles so
as we have more and more electric
vehicles in a market eventually will
have them coming off electric vehicle
maybe they won't be good enough for
transportation the ranges too short but
we can still take them out and use them
in grid application for example by using
them to buffer electricity for solar and
these simulation basically tells you
that by the beginning of 2020 we will
begin to see significant amount of
battery come off electric vehicle and
this second life use of batteries
represents a very large market as well
and economics is not fully understood
and there's a lot of opportunity in
thinking about how do we effectively
take batteries out of electric vehicles
and repurpose them for other
applications such as the grid so I'm out
of time today so maybe I would just say
a few more words I didn't have time to
get into the specific technologies here
the take-home message here is there are
a lot of different technology and each
one of them will have a different
metrics it will not meet all the
requirements there's no silver bullet
R&D is ongoing for everything I'm
showing you here and more and let me
stop with this take-home message here
which is looking at the big opportunity
my opinion is that we cannot work on
technology without considering the
business needs and the use case so I
spent about half the talk talking about
the various use cases how the grit
companies could be using battery to
generate revenue we can be looking at
transportation as a way to replace
internal combustion engines we talked
about the economic
behind it on the right hand side we have
the technology I only talked about
electrochemical today but there are many
more and really it is about matching the
to finding the right technology for the
specific business cases and identifying
the need to further develop technology
to meet certain techno kanami goals and
I think this is what is needed to really
see the
tration of renewable electricity and the
role that energy storage will play so
let me stop here and thank you very much
for listening now we have a few minutes
for Boyle to answer a few of your
questions all right so the first
question is what are the challenges to
recycling batteries at a large scale and
what are the associated environmental
impacts how does technology reducing the
environmental footprint this is a very
loaded question on my say-so let me
answer the last question first the
environmental footprint is not an easy
question to answer you often you know
see and you know on the license placing
this is a zero emission vehicle that is
not entirely true it depends on how the
electricity was generated and it also
you need to think about how much
emission went into making the technology
so here at Stanford elsewhere folks are
doing analysis on the lifecycle
footprint of these technologies so as
you compare different technology you
have to think about what is the emission
that went into the extraction of the raw
material the manufacturing and the
assembly of the technology and that have
to be considered there's no simple
answer and one can simulate what the
carbon pay by time you would have for a
particular technology
so definitely battery it is not a zero
emission technology if you consider the
lifetime the other aspect from the
listener is recycling this will be
crucially important it will be a huge
industry and let me comment on from two
perspective first is economics so
recycling will only be done if its
economy lay viable and he will be
economically viable for example when the
raw material cost goes up so people will
be developing ways to recycle the
batteries so that can be sold so if you
think about the budget for recycling
it's basically how much you get paid for
the material that you extract on the
engineering side recycling is very
interesting when you think about
recycling you think about boiling it
down to the fundamental building blocks
maybe extracting COBOL again that's the
most expensive element in a battery but
this
is very challenging so one big
opportunity could be can we recycle
battery without having to reduce it down
to the original make up of the battery
can we for example think about
rejuvenating a battery or regenerating a
battery as a way of recycling and reuse
are supposed to deconstructing the
battery and one else I have to think
about the safety of recycling so how do
you take a part of the battery safely
and how do we design battery for
recycling so can we design it with
recycling in mind so the form factor
already allows easy recycling this
participant wrote California recently
announced for partnering solar panels
and all new homes beginning in January
1st 2020 what are your thoughts on the
effects of over generation potential
curtailment
the over generation is already there so
as I showed in the duck curve we have to
ramp up you know half of the Australia
grid in 3 hours in California this is
how significant the problem is so this
is only going to get worse and storage
is an obvious answer but let me discuss
it briefly what companies say for
example in California PG&E and Southern
California cenar doing so there are a
lot of legacy power plant based on
natural gas and one way to do it is to
simply power up the natural gas power
plant the hardware is already there
they're not being fully utilized so that
is the easy way battery based technology
or other technology is important as well
but currently the investment needed to
get that up and running basically the
capital expenditure needed is enormous
so looking forward I think one thing
that the policymakers should consider is
as we mandate more and more renewable
electricity generation we must also
create policy to give incentive to more
storage and we're seeing this already
for example in California we have this
self generation credit that give several
thousand dollars to homeowners to
install
battery system at home so these are sort
of complementary policy that we look at
I didn't really mention the policy
aspect today but that's another huge
opportunity is to think about the rural
policy in terms of shaping how renewable
technology included generation and
storage would be deployed thank you
last question how can I get involved in
you know this field especially in power
yeah I think this is also a very
difficult question to answer I think you
have taken the first step
energy storage is extremely complex and
it is rapidly evolving it changes by the
month there are new technologies
emerging all the time so my
recommendation would be to get caught up
by learning more about the technologies
we have today and continue to follow it
there are many startups here in Silicon
Valley and elsewhere pursuing the
development of energy technology but I
think as people who are interesting the
technology you have to be able to assess
it so what market is the technology
addressing what are the economical
driving forces were the val ability of
scaling up right you hear a lot of
popular press and a lot of hype around
say battery technology but I think one
important skill to have is to be able to
look at the technology and say okay this
is really going to have an impact as
scale or this is hard and I think this
is one of the things that you can try to
learn for example from our program here
great well thank you so much everyone
for joining us we will be sending out a
copy of this presentation within a week
and thank you all and we hope you enjoy
the rest of your day
thank you
you